das heutige video wird ein sehr
persönliches und sehr spannendes video
leute denn ich habe ein sehr sehr
interessantes video auf youtube gefunden
über eine gntm teilnehmerin die darüber
berichtet wie sie früher in ihrer
schulzeit extrem gemobbt wurde und ich
habe genau dieses video für unser
heutiges video ausgewählt weil ich ja
selbst in meiner schulzeit schon morgen
erfahrung gemacht haben weil es extrem
viele leute da draußen gibt die gleichen
erfahrungen machen oder aber die freunde
oder verwandte haben die diese erfahrung
machen und deswegen leute let's go
jeder tag ein neuer albtraum zu den
ersten worten kann ich schon direktor
hätten leute also ich kann ja heutzutage
gott sei dank auf diese zeit
zurückschauen und sagen ich habe mich
extrem weiterentwickelt ich bin jetzt
mittlerweile ein mensch mit einem sehr
gesunden freundeskreis chiapas erreicht
in meinem leben so ist alles gut bei mir
aber wenn wir noch mal die zeit zurück
dann geht es damals war dann kann ich
mich der darstellung auf den
veranschlagten ich weiß auch genau und
dieses video zeigt ein bisschen da oben
auf das thema aufmerksam zu machen und
auch den leuten die das jetzt gerade
durchleben kraft zu geben weshalb genau
wie ich so vor ferienbeginn immer im
bett lag mega hatte ja ich will nicht in
die schule weil es halt eben so abging
bis julia sogar im krankenhaus findet
okay das ist das wirklich das ist
wirklich kein könnte also wenn ihr
jedoch dieses video seht ihr so die
schilderung von der weth fragt man sich
nicht warum machen leute das also warum
haben leute die spaß an brutalität also
spaß daran anderen leuten weh zu tun ich
habe da für mich persönlich selbst noch
nicht die ultimative antwort gefunden
aber eine antwort habe ich sehr wohl
gefunden leute und zwar ist die antwort
die das die leute die auf anderen
rumhacken ich weiß viele sagen dass aber
es ist einfach ein fakt so oft einfach
selbst die unsichersten münchen sag ich
mal sind die da draußen gibt es ist ein
fake leute die sind vielleicht größte
sich vielleicht stärker aber innerlich
haben die einen heidenspaß negativ
aufzufallen deswegen hat es auch
andersrum so nicht julius 13 und er hat
gerade die schule gewechselt als das
mobbing beginnt einen grund warum
millionen mitschüler sie nicht leiden
können erzählt sie
gibt es nicht fühle ich dicker das ist
zu krank
das wirklich so krank dass es fast eins
zu eins war eine geschichte ich war
zwölf als sie in eine neue schule
gekommen denn damals haben sie mal meine
eltern getrennt erzählt wir sind einen
anderen ort gezogen ich war zwölf wurde
gerade 13 also genauso alt wie sie neue
stadt neue schule und dann war dann ging
es los
dem hat was man gesagt es wurde alles so
blöd dargestellt und man wurde als darf
fertig gemacht und die sache die sache
dabei ist leute dass die leute die das
machen oftmals gar nicht realisieren was
sie damit auslösen andere personen ich
glaube tatsächlich in vielen fällen ist
es gar nicht so dass so ein mordender
personen sodass ultimativ böse wesen ist
sondern die person ist einfach dumm und
check nicht was sie mit ihren eigenen
mit ihren eigenen handlungen auslöst die
schülerin aus dortmund erlebt was laut
statistik jeder sechste schüler in
deutschland teilweise täglicher trägt
die ersten steigend denn die zahl der
doping-fälle an deutschen schulen steigt
okay es gibt mal kurzzeitig und lagerten
durch leute so übels ernstes videos über
mobbing über schwerster phasen in seinem
eigenen persönlichen leben gerade in so
einer kritischen phase wieder kindheit
und hoffe ich so zu ihr
ganz ehrlich flirt doch noch mit der
kamera post nochmal mobbingfälle an
deutschen schulen werden sagt das lachen
nicht vergessen was ernstes thema also
es ist das eine werbefilm für mobbing
doch sind kann sich julia so vor ihren
mitschülern nicht schnell bleibt ist
nicht mehr nur bei verbalen
beleidigungen
ja ja ja ja krass ist wirklich crazy
leute ist wirklich es ist wirklich
schade dass es sowas überhaupt gibt es
ist wirklich schade weil solche sachen
solche mobbing phasen schwere schäden
glaube ich den leuten verursache
natürlich zu unterschiedlich schweren
gerade bei manchen mehr bei manchen
weniger aber das muss man im nachhinein
erst wieder aufbauen sich da erst wieder
raus kämpfen das ist auch mit das
dramatische sie sind nicht nur die jahre
die in der schule wo man das erlebt
natürlich die hölle sind sondern die
zeit danach ist aber auch davon
beeinflusst
habt ihr das gesehen leute am ende von
diesem schock man sieht ihr richtig im
gesicht an wie sie damit strahlt sie hat
das geht ganz hat relativ gefasst
erzählt aber am ende sieht man wirklich
die emotionen nicht ich kann da komplett
zu ryland genau diese sache irgendwie
sport sache irgendwie versteckt im müll
oder sowas und was für kranke [ __ ]
das waren schlimmer noch keiner glaubt
oder nicht ihr auch zahlreiche schulen
gespräche in julian erfolglos insgesamt
vergeben eineinhalb jahre bis julia die
schule wechselt ja viel wichtiger sei
jetzt dieser videobeitrag mit julia b
oder mit sebastian k es ist genauso
leute so viele von euch werden auch
leighton sondern man erzählt den eltern
davon die eltern so hören
machen aber auch nicht wirklich was weil
sie ihre eigenen probleme haben oder
nicht checken dass es ernst ist oder was
auch immer man spricht in der schule an
die lehrer so also bei uns gibt es nicht
oder wenn überhaupt sprechen das mal
wenn man sie wirklich belagert mal ganz
kurz dem unterricht und das verändert
sich nichts
ich hab mich gerade gefragt leute
welchen rat ich meinem alten ich geben
würde und ich glaube einer der
wichtigsten punkte ist selbstbewusstsein
aufbauen sich mit dem thema
selbstbewusstsein selbstwertgefühl
befassen und da ansetzen da aufbauen
sich hilfe suchen auf jeden fall mit
leuten darüber reden und wenn die
übergriffe teilweise auch körperlich
sind dann finde ich auch so was wie
kampfsport persönlich eine geile option
ok ja gut für sie also ich würde das
jetzt nicht über mich selbst behaupten
ich kenne sie ihr natürlich auch
überhaupt nicht so 0
ich finde das ist jetzt fast schon
wieder so ein bisschen übertrieben würde
ich aus meiner perspektive sagen also
ich glaube das ganz ganz wenige leute
auf der ganzen welt überhaupt an dem
punkt dass sie sagen können ja kein
anderer mensch kann der war es natürlich
interessiert es uns was andere leute
über uns denken so sind wir einfach
veranlagt wollte das in unseren genen
menschen sind soziale wesen also ich
glaube man hätte auf jeden fall aber ich
glaube ganz egal sind einem die urteile
von anderen leuten auch nach so einer
faser nicht es gibt aber noch ganz
lustigen teil dieses video hier das ist
so ein videobeitrag über 3g rtm
teilnehmer japan 20 gntm 20 20 jahren
ist eben juli ap die gemobbt wurde eine
andere ist vivien die depression hat das
amateur woods ich mich gar nicht äußern
kann also da will ich auch nichts
falsches zu sagen und dann eben diesem
video wo quasi so lebensbeichten drin
mitgeteilt werden ist auch noch eine
dritte tamara was ist ihre beichte ihre
beichte ist dass ihr traum ist berühmt
zu werden
doch auch tamara hatte viel mit sich zu
kämpfen die halb mazedonierin die in
wien auf externe verfolgt seit ihrer
kindheit nur 1
also leute verstehen wir nicht fällt
klar das ist natürlich auch legitim und
so träume zu haben und an den zu
arbeiten dafür rein zu halten wir das
sehr sehr wichtig auf jeden fall es ist
einfach nur die zusammenstellung diese
bio design wirklich geil wirklich so
zwei ultra krasse probleme diesen
menschen prägen können also dritte
person meine persönliche beichte ist
ich möchte follower auf instagram dass
ich bald da kommt so ich würde alles
gute bei ihrem bei ihrem projekt zu bei
ihrem ziel ich hoffe dass sie gas gibt
dafür dass es funktioniert doch
ausgerechnet die aufmerksamkeit wird
tamara anfangs zum verhängnis wie viele
in ihrem alter kämpft jedoch bis vor
zwei jahren mit starken selbstzweifeln
die fahren durch instagram weiter
verstärkt werden auch auf jeden fall ein
großes thema unserer zeit leute was
macht eigentlich social media mit uns
was macht das mit unseren köpfen die wir
einfach dass unser denken dass wir die
ganze zeit immer nur so highlight
behielt immer noch so highlights aus dem
leben von anderen leuten sehen und wird
erhalt währenddessen zu hause auf der
couch sitzen und es vielleicht noch
einkaufen oder chips um es besser was
bin ich eigentlich für ein würmchen also
leute ja es gibt heutzutage immer noch
viele unserer welt was nicht richtig ist
dann wo man gegen vorgehen muss euch
leute einfach nur versuchen würden ein
bisschen mehr mitgefühl für andere leute
zu entwickeln dann wird uns das schon
weit bringen ich muss mir auf jeden fall
mal gedanken machen wie ich mich gegen
mobbing engagieren kann leute ihr könnt
euch engagieren den vorschlag ist findet
hier um einen kanal ab und ich bin da
schon raus was gut und schreibt eure
story falls sie einen hauptgegner die
kommentare